the bottom 80 percent of men are
competing for the bottom twenty percent
of women on Tinder and the top eighty
percent of women are competing for the
top twenty percent of men so this means
that most men to most women are
effectively invisible and most women to
a small number of men are effectively
usable so are you saying that this is a
shift in culture with pay with jobs with
status and it's sort of like a byproduct
of things or that women aren't actually
attracted to these men again I don't
mean to try and put a downer on how
achieving women there's no reason that
they should hold themselves back from
doing this but there is a difficult
situation you've got going on here it's
hard for men to raise themselves up
because it seems like women outperform
men in education and employment when
they have the breaks taken off the only
reason that we seem to have male
superiority in the past is because women
had the breaks put on them but you can't
get around the fact that on average
women want to date a man who's more
educated than they are especially when
you consider that educational outcomes
open the doors to employment
opportunities exactly